the Secretary of Veterans Affairs did
not mince words about Devin Kelley's
service in the Air Force we spoke to
David Shokan yesterday at a VA medical
facility in New York and asked about the
role his agency might have played in
preventing the shooting is there
something that the VA could have done to
help him well he served in the Air Force
but he was dishonorably discharged I do
not consider him a veteran I consider
him a criminal and while I don't know
the motivation why anybody would do such
a horrific act and whether there was a
component of mental illness I considered
this an evil man who would do what he
did the VA does not care for
dishonorably discharged people have left
the service so he would have been able
to seek mental health help at the VA no
one of the first acts that I did a
secretary is that I extended mental
health services to those that were other
than honorably discharged but when
you're dishonorably discharged as this
gentleman was it's because you've
committed a crime and really did
something horrific so we do not take
care of them in the VA system and
frankly people who have worn the uniform
don't want to be associated with people
like that and in our next hour we're
gonna hear from ashokan about why more
veterans than ever are waiting for care
plus the only Obama administration
holdover in the cabinet reflects on his
relationship with President Trump